[Music]
thank you
visual Illusions those fascinating memes
and party tricks that seem so right for
interpretation or misinterpretation have
an endless capacity to Mesmerize delight
and yes divide us remember the dress
that lit up the internet friendships
tested family dinners ruined all over
the question of whether this dress is
blue and black or white and gold or this
image that had everyone from Harry
Potter author JK Rowling to the
president of El Salvador weighing in on
whether it's a horse or a seal a fish or
a donkey
maybe these images Fascinate us because
most of the time the act of looking and
seeing is something that seems so
Elemental so effortless
visual Illusions Force us to stop and
consider how our sense of sight actually
works and whether it is all that
reliable and for that reason they are a
valuable tool for researchers trying to
understand the mysterious process of how
we actually see the world
it's a question people have been asking
and debating for Millennia now we've
come a long way from ancient Greece from
Plato who believe that light emanated
from our eyes provoking an interaction
between the object and the Soul
Aristotle then theorized that sight
occurred when the air around an object
and the liquid inside of our eyes formed
a connection a thousand years later in
medieval Cairo an Arab mathematician and
physicist named Al Hazen argued that
Vision starts when light bounces off of
objects and enters the eye and travels
to the back of the brain which is the
organ that is really giving us sight and
remarkably Al Hazen got it pretty much
right today Vision scientists agree that
we see not with our eyes but with our
brains and it turns out that the brain
is doing this with strikingly minimal
information
light enters the eye as a stream of tiny
particles photons at the back of the eye
in the retina microscopic photoreceptors
rods and cones as they are called
transform those bits of light into
signals that travel along the optic
nerve to the visual cortex much as Al
Hayes impostulated
even more remarkable only a small part
of the retina the center called the
fovea season high resolution so to see
something clearly our phobia has to be
pointed directly at it to get a sense of
how small an area the phobia can take in
at any given moment you can draw a
letter on each of your thumbnails and
hold them at arm's length if you do that
you'll notice that focusing on one of
your thumbnails makes the letter on the
other thumbnail a pear blurry for this
reason we all unconsciously move our
eyes around constantly scanning the
world to gather up these tiny patches of
high resolution signal
to put it all together the brain must
quickly fill gaps in the visual
information it's receiving creating a
picture of the physical world that seems
Rich coherent and convincing all in
fractions of a second leading visual
scientists to ask
how exactly do our brains accomplish all
that how much of what we see is
objective reality and how much of what
we see is really the product of some
fast and sometimes flawed interpretation
to examine those questions each of our
guests tonight uses the study of visual
Illusions to try to catch the mind in
the act of seeing asking in essence how
by fooling the eye we can reveal the
truth about our visual perceptions of
the world
Susana Martinez Conde joins us from New
York City where she directs the
laboratory of Integrative neuroscience
at SUNY downstate Medical Center she is
one of the world's leading Authorities
on the Neuroscience of magic welcome
Susana
Rodrigo Keon kirago joins us from
University of Leicester in the UK where
he is the director of the center for
systems neuroscience
he studies how memory impacts visual
perception and is the discoverer of what
has been called the Jennifer Aniston
neuron something that we're going to
hear about later tonight welcome Rodrigo
and finally we have Emily palchettis who
joins us from New York City where she is
an associate professor of psychology at
New York University she studies how our
psychological states can change what we
see and how our experience and
motivations can influence how we see
everything from visual Illusions to
police altercations to athletic
challenges welcome Emily and welcome to
you all so I just want to begin to set
the stage so it's on a why and all of
you can weigh in on this why visual
Illusions why are they a good way in to
that kind of Investigation
well the thing about Illusions is that
we often tend to think about them as the
errors of perception where the brain
gets it wrong but this is not correct
the fact is that Illusions are not only
inherent to all of our perception they
are not the exception they are the rule
and in fact they're necessary would we
wouldn't be able to perceive if
Illusions did not exist the way they do
Rodrigo your take on that yeah I think
it's I mean you're attacking a very nice
and philosophical issue you know I mean
it goes back to well at least two can't
I will say because we don't see the
reality as it is outside we see our
perception of reality the way we
interpreted it and I think one of the
take-home messages about how the brain
works I mean one of the things I learned
in all these years is that we don't see
the things as they are outside we just
take very very little information and we
make a construction of the reality
inside our heads so actually we do see
with the brain the eye is just a sensory
organ that brings this little
information we capture and then we
create all this construction inside our
heads and visual Illusions is when we
try to fill in information that somehow
lead us to see things that are striking
yeah Emily
first thoughts in all honesty I came to
study visual Illusions because they're
just fun yeah but more scientifically
the reason that I study them is that it
gives us some insight into bigger social
issues like polarization in our society
visual Illusions are a very tight
experimental stimulus that we can
present that that can help us understand
why does somebody see it one way why
does someone else see it an entirely
different way and from that basic
understanding of the visual illusion we
can extrapolate to understand bigger
social issues that might be related to
political partisanship and other
concerns within society that are leading
us to have very different
interpretations of what's happening in
the world around us jumping off from all
those comments I mean what we're going
to do here tonight is examine some very
specific visual Illusions to make this
really concrete and and visual as the
subject is and just to give a sense of
what it means to have the brain create
things that do seem to be contrary to
what we think is out there in the world
or examples where different people with
different experience and different
preconceptions we'll see different
things in the very same image and so
forth and to that end let's just jump in
with the first example a very simple
illusion I think many people in our
audience have seen you know you look at
this and you know I think everybody sees
a triangle in the middle but then you
ask yourself is it really there so
Rodrigo I mean take this first one away
what are we seeing here what does it
tell us well basically we are inferring
the form of a triangle just from the
borders and actually you can I mean you
can make it more brutal I mean you can
you can put the pagmas a bit further
away and but
the moment you see the borders that they
coincide and that they form a line we
are feeling this information in our head
and we're actually perceiving these as
lines that form a triangle and it's very
simple to break this solution you just
rotate it tiny with the back ones and
then you have the borders not coinciding
with each other just a tiny misalignment
we completely break the illusion so it's
it's a major principle right is that we
don't see always in front of us we see
very tiny bits of information and we're
constructing something in our head in
this case from the borders we are
constructing the image of a triangle and
it's impossible not to see it yeah you
know I found this one particularly
interesting the example that you talk
about rotating the the the Pac-Man
certainly takes the image away too but I
found it interesting if you mask it by
just say putting a piece of paper over
two of the three Pac-Man and then slowly
move that piece of paper ask yourself
when does the triangle appear sort of
what's the minimum information necessary
for this illusion to work I presume it
may be the same for everybody but for me
I had to get past the second Pac-Man and
just a little hint of the third and that
was enough for it to sort of just snap
into focus and as you say you just can't
unsee it at that point so Savannah you
had a point that you wanted to make on
this to me with this solution reveals is
a couple of important Concepts first off
this uh famous classical uh kanitza
triangle
it's constructed with very little
information so this is a feeling in
illusion but more generally it reveals
that with very scarce information we can
construct in our minds a pretty complex
concept so the brain doesn't need a
whole lot to go on but the other thing
that I would address is that there is
critical information having said this
there is critical information that this
Pacman are provided because this is not
Just an Illusion about building a shape
from a little bit of the edges these are
portions of the edges that are very
specific particularly the corners and we
have shown for instance in my laboratory
that even at the level of the retina
you're going to have stronger responses
to Corners than to straight edges and in
fact if you open the Pac-Man and you you
had semi-circles for instance and you
push them against the size of the
triangle so you have an equal portion of
the triangle being revealed by the
Pac-Man but you wouldn't touch the
corners it would be much harder to make
out the triangle from these illusory
Contours so let's go from there to
another class of visual Illusions and
this is um sort of a very powerful
example of contrast that that the eye
and the brain is really focused upon
relative differences as opposed to
Absolute so tell us tell us what we're
seeing here I remember I was a postoker
Caltech in California
and we have a lot of speakers coming to
give seminars and one of the speakers
was a very good visual scientist from
MIT called Ed Adelson he showed exactly
the solution on on the screen and then
he said you know what the squares the
checks of A and B are exactly the same
color and then we'll look at the the
checkerboard and we say no no way I mean
he means something else and then he's he
said I will say it again the check on
Square a and the checker on square B are
exactly the same color and we all said
no this cannot be and they are and you
see that and you don't believe it but
for example I mean there are many ways
to show that you can you can occlude the
rest of the image and just show the two
checks without the turkey war and they
are the same color it's amazing and then
you see the whole image again and they
are not the same color
so
physically they are the same color it is
exactly the same tone of gray but when
the the moment you see the whole image
you cannot your brain cannot avoid
sending differently and why is that well
because this is a checkerboard and you
know that some checks are white and some
others are black so you cannot see
seeing one of the checks darker than the
other because of the Distribution on the
charcoal because you know that one
corresponds to a black check and the
other one corresponds to a y check and
the illusion works because you are
assuming they're white and you're
assuming they are black and you are not
really processing every single Pixel of
color in this checkerboard you just
having an inference based on on your
assumptions and you just rely on that
and actually you cannot bypass them the
assumptions Drive the perception the
assumption that a color is white then
one check is White and the other is
black is what drives your perception not
the physical stimulus in this case so
therefore because of this information
because we know how a checkable looks
like we see it differently although it's
exactly the same color and even if you
know that if you know that it's the same
you cannot see the same and I found this
really remarkable so if someone had
never seen a checkerboard before is the
effect the same or is it is it any
different if they don't have that
preconceived notion
I would argue that it would nevertheless
work because what the visual system is
doing here besides having a prediction
or an assumption about a checkerboard is
that we're making an assumption about
lighting and shade and so that a green
cylinder appears to be casting a shade
and so we are a discounting the
illuminum that's basically this is based
on what we uh called uh lightness
constancy or brightness constancy in the
visual system and what this basically
means is that we see an object as having
the same brightness or having the same
color and they're very different
illumination conditions and this is why
for example you take a newspaper and you
look at it under artificial lighting and
then you go and you take it outside uh
at noon on a sunny day and you see in
both instances black letters on a white
background however the photons if you
were to measure with a photometer the
the light energy uh reflected off of the
black letters outside this this these
are higher luminance than the white
background when you are inside under
artificial light conditions but your
visual system is taken into account the
illumination the general uh lighting of
the of the scene and its discount in the
illuminant so that's what's happening
here with these squares that uh because
they're not just plain squares but we're
interpreting them as falling in the
shade or not then you are discounting
this information and applying it to make
your best guesstimate you being the
visual system so I so I gather the
reason chance one of the shortcuts that
Evolution has provided Us in order that
we can see continuity in the world that
we don't see an object in one lighting
condition and a moment later see that
same object in another lighting
condition and think they're completely
unrelated in order to see the continuity
of the physical world we have this
shortcut that subtracts out the
differences in the environment in order
that we can identify those objects that
are consistent and continuous this is
another one I don't know if anyone can
take us through what we're seeing here
the chess pieces certainly look
different
but I gather in this illusion they're
the same is that correct they are
absolutely the same pixel by pixel these
chess pieces they're exactly identical
uh they're not black and white they're
all something in between again you're
not for the visual system black and
white are not absolute terms everything
depends on contrast and context and so
we have this sort of like clouds
enveloping these pieces and we're taking
this background this context into
account and deducing these pieces must
be black when uh we see this sort of
like a whitish clouds around them and
these pieces must be wide when we see
the dark clouds around the pieces but
they're again pixel by pixel is exactly
the same stimulus before we move on I
just wanted to mention that the
wonderful chess piece solution this is
by Bart Anderson and John winnower and
that uh it uh it actually made made a
cover of uh a nature magazine some years
back if I remember correct yeah it's
totally totally remarkable I mean I
think I'm having the same reaction that
Rodrigo had were your graduate student
you were recounting that story of seeing
the talk because you look at this and
you can't help but think that they are
radically different there's another
example with colors this is all Shades
of Gray black and white I think we have
a a little famous visual demonstration
of color can someone take us through I
mean what we're seeing here
in terms of this uh the moving Square
illusion is kind of it's a basically the
similar concept now emotion that makes
it more striking we have the same I
believe gray square that is moving left
and right but we're going to interpret
it not only as having different
lightness but having different colors
depending on the background it's
hard-pressed not to describe this as
some kind of error I know you cautioned
us early on not to think of it in those
terms but is it wrong to think of this
as
a kind of limitation of our visual
system to provide actual information
about a physical object in the external
world but rather to always provide this
comparative information of the object
relative to its environment you have to
weigh pros and cons and so our visual
system is not optimized or it hasn't
evolved to give us the most accurate
picture possible is the good enough
picture that will allow us to to survive
and to pass on the genes to the Next
Generation and to be able to frankly
recognize her children under different
lighting environments inside and outside
the cave so that we don't eat them yes
that's a good thing is everything that
we've been talking about for the most
part has been sort of a more or less a
two-dimensional kind of visual illusion
but they're these really powerful
more three-dimensional visual Illusions
I don't know how familiar you all are
with this particular example where
there's a real sense of of waviness
that's happening in the ground here so
what is it about the visual system that
allows you to be fooled into thinking
that there's this wavy structure or at
least cognitively I'm pretty certain
it's a flat ground do we understand this
one well well I I love this example and
that uh there are similar patterns that
bring up perceptual Illusions and the
architecture together there's another
famous pattern similar to this in some
ways in LA ramblas in in Barcelona but
to me with these really highlights is
the fact that
we are building a 3D concept where there
is no as you said uh we have a flat
floor but we have this sort of like a
waviness a bit of a 3D concept maybe
some motion uh but the reason why this
may look 3D or it may look wavy these
are basically the same neural mechanisms
that are being uh hacked into by the the
artist that that produce the solution
that allow us to see motion and 3D in in
our daily lives because for one 3D is
always our perception of 3D is a brain
construct because even though we have 3D
in the real world objects have volume
and so on by the time the visual
information
arrives to a retina a retinas are
fundamentally flat surfaces so whatever
3D existed in the world is lost in our
eyes and then it has to be rebuilt in
the brain so our experiential 3D is an
illusion you know another class of
ambiguous scenes of course make use of
the 3D environment but in a way that our
brains can sort of parse in two
different ways right the simplest being
just the Necker Cube the ordinary Cube
you know all of us you look at that Cube
you blink your eyes a few times and it
looks like you're looking either inside
the cube or outside the cube there's
another wonderful very famous one that
we've all of course seen I don't know if
it's called the mother or the wife
illusion I don't know if that's PC to
discuss it in that language any longer
but you know you look at this image and
if you stare at it long enough it does
bounce back and forth between two
different interpretations so so
Emily do you have thoughts on this is
this again an experience in forming a
perception is it highlighting some
Shortcut in the visual system that is
allowing the artist to manipulate us to
see two different things depending on
how we blink our eyes
I mean in some sense it's it's
for ambiguity
first it's just
it's your brain really wants to
understand what we're looking at and in
part meaning and of course there's
meaning in all of these things but it
may not be readily available or
something for us to be able to to
comment on and articulate right away in
these cases the Necker Cube and and the
two different women image we're trying
to decide like well what's the
foreground and what's the background
what's closer to us what's actually
further away even though we're seeing a
two-dimensional image we know that there
is greater dimensionality actually there
and we're trying to make sense of that
on the Fly and that's why we can flip
between seeing the Necker cube is one
that's going up or that we're looking
down upon or whether what's popping out
to us is the older woman or the younger
woman
um and that's why we can also fluctuate
because both of those possibilities are
correct yeah and you've done some work
on I guess what's it called the the
horse and seal illusion which is kind of
a variation on on the same theme so you
can take us through what we're seeing
here
sure so if you haven't seen this before
and I gave you a second or so in that
one second you'll make sense of it
you're gonna see something here and
about 80 percent of people see this as a
horse they see this as a horse's head
now for most people then since that's
the predominant response if I were to
say but there's something else also
that's also correct there is a seal
the reaction I get often is like what or
no way right but for some people those
20 they do see that and they have a hard
time accepting what 80 of the room says
which is that there is a horse there so
the seal is you know it's a it's the
full body of a seal with his with his
little face down in the bottom left
corner and his and his tail protruding
up in case that was a challenge for some
people to pull out now they're you know
where our eyes land first might be one
of those factors that help us to make
sense of of one interpretation rather
than another the bottom left corner
again is a particularly important spot
on this image and if that's where we
look first and we try to piece those
those little bits together that might be
really important for us seeing the snout
or the most protruding part of of the
horse there but if her eyes first went
to the upper right corner maybe that's
going to inform or make it easier for us
to see the seal so part of this
interpretation is based on where do our
eyes go first and what input are we
allowing our brain to try to make sense
of and piece together and resolve the
ambiguity of which then informs our
understanding of the rest of the image
but there's more to it than that it's
not just where our eyes go and how we
piece together the local little edges
and black and white features that are
there but there's psychological baggage
that we bring to the table too our past
experiences maybe one but in my lab
something that we looked at was
motivation what do we want to see and if
there's something that we want to see is
that also having an influence on what
people come to see interpret this image
as first so the way that we did this is
uh we sort of we set this up as a game
we told people who came into our lab
that we're going to do a taste testing
experiment we would we're going to have
you sample some things in the lab we
would love to know like a marketing
tests what what do you think about the
quality of these what should we Market
it for how much should we price this out
what do you like it or do you not
um but you know a scientists we want to
make sure that there's people are random
assigned to experience some food or
another food and we're going to let the
computer decide which of these two
possibilities for your taste testing
marketing experience you're going to get
in a sort of roulette or or slot machine
setup the computer is just going to
randomly present an image if the image
happens to be a farm animal
you'll get to taste Jelly Bellies really
wonderful jelly beans exotic wonderful
expensive jelly beans and tell us about
your experience there but if it pulls up
a sea animal you're going to sample
canned beans gelatinous partially
liquefied canned beans far less
interesting for most people than the
Jelly Belly candies so that's how we set
up people's desires their motivations
that what they want they want in this
case to see farm animals they don't want
to see the sea animals because they want
to eat the Jelly Bellies
then we show them this image for just
one second that's long enough for them
to reach one interpretation but not long
enough for them to reach another
interpretation and when we do that we
find that in more than three quarters of
people see this as a horse but when we
switch the motivations when we switch
that point structure and instead for
other participants say if it shows you a
sea animal then you'll eat the Jelly
Bellies and farm animals mean that
you'll have the liquefied canned beans
then we see that ratio flip in dramatic
ways now three quarters of people
two-thirds of people can see the seal
wouldn't that what that's not the
natural distribution and that's not what
people in another uh you know rewarding
condition
um had experienced so when we induce
that want or that desire we we have an
additional impact on how people resolve
the ambiguity of this figure wow that's
really remarkable another really
powerful example at least to me of
ambiguity and how our brain tries to
resolve it I I'd never seen this this
video before but can we do this little
experiment here I'm sure all of you are
familiar with it but if you if you look
right in the center at the cross and
then allow these images of famous
celebrities to flash by
if you're like anybody else I guess as
the images flash by it's really
freaky what what you see right I mean
distortions all over the place of these
of these famous faces so so Susanna look
do we understand what's happening here
inside of our brains it's mainly a
matter of contrast so again uh this time
in the in the face recognition domain
this is this highlights that for the
brain there are no absolute terms and so
the way the solution works is that you
have all of these faces of these uh
generally Beautiful People A-list actors
and uh that individually are gonna be
looking just fine better than fine but
because of the way that they are lined
up our brains are forced to make this
online comparison and they're very
specifically selected so that you will
have somebody say with a normal average
size nose right after somebody who has a
small nose and our brain is going to be
exaggerating the size of the average
nose in comparison and so on and so
forth so the features of each of these
individual people because the brain is
constantly comparing with what came
before they become caricatures of
themselves yeah I mean do you find this
as mind-blowing as as I do or maybe is
this like a hackneyed video in the field
and you're like oh not that not not the
famous face video again or does this oh
no this is this is a wonderful illusion
it's uh very powerful so let's look at
another visual illusion so uh Emily
maybe you can take us through what we're
seeing here you know it starts as a
bunch of splotches and then resolves
into something more familiar so what
happens as we look at this image
well sure if this if this is the first
time that you're seeing this snowstorm
you might be wondering like well what is
this and your brain might be quickly
trying to couple some of the the black
bits together or you might be trying to
effortfully recombine them because you
you just don't even know what this is
if you have seen it before you know
exactly what it is that you're looking
at for me uh you know I have read
through all of the textbooks that
showcase this so I cannot unsee what's
in here which is a dog it's an image of
a dog of a Dalmatian in fact
now I wonder if having said that if
people who hadn't seen it before can now
pick out the dog that's in there and
once you have it's so hard to just see
this as a random collection of dots as
the snowstorm that we first opened this
up as again because we have that past
experience that resolved the
configuration of dots in a particular
way perhaps sort of imbued some
connections between these dots that
aren't actually there but is essential
for us putting to for us to put together
the visual experience of where the dog's
face is where the body is where the legs
are so Rodrigo do we have a sense of
what's happening at a neurological level
when the brain is able to find coherence
and see the dalmatian in this image
versus the state that it started in
where it's just a bunch of splotches on
the page
well I mean you you clearly at some
point you recognize that they say
Dalmatian I mean when I see this image I
know this image I immediately see a dog
I mean I don't see the snow anymore I
just hear Dalmatians straight but it's
because I have seen it before so I think
the moment we see that and we recognize
that we are creating a representation
that is slightly different to the first
initial representation so we add more
information to that and we somehow
encode in our brain this information
that I mean here is not just a random
set of of snowflakes and so on it is it
is the image of a dog and we cannot undo
it I mean it's impossible for me not to
see a dog anymore you know what's
interesting though and again I don't
know if this is peculiar to me or
whether it's maybe intrinsic to these
kinds of images
I had never seen this image before until
quite recently and at first I went
through exactly the process that Emily
and Rodriguez are describing I didn't
see anything at all and then all of a
sudden the dalmatian popped out at me
and then I couldn't unsee it as you're
saying except
when I change the scale of the image I
can't help but fiddle I'm a fiddler so
so I I made the image much different
size than when I initially encountered
it it made it much smaller and then I
lost the dalmatian for about 10 or 15
seconds I stared I said and then the
dalmatian came back so is there an
element of recapitulating the process
that you first saw the image and if you
radically change the scale or maybe the
lighting or things of that sort you can
unsee the thing that and otherwise would
be something that you couldn't erase
that image I think what you're doing is
when you see the image I I see some
features it's not that I see a dog
straight I see some features of the dog
that gives me the image of the dog so I
see the face I know more or less what
the face is because I have seen this
image before and then I can recognize
immediately the posture of the dog and I
can get through the whole body now if
you start feeling with the image as you
said and you lost this scale and you
lost where the head must be as soon then
I can understand that it will take you
some time to figure out okay what is the
exact position of the dog now but once
you recognize this feature I mean it's
kind of like the whole thing appears
again so Susana is this a is this a
nature or or nurture in your in your
opinion this particular illusion well
it's it's it's both nature and nurture
can come together in this particular
image is that our brain is always trying
to solve ambiguity something that we
don't realize because we have been used
to seeing uh our whole lives those of us
who are sighted that is is that
um the visual input is just very
ambiguous even at the level of a retinas
we have a constant compound between the
size of an object and the distance of
that object from us and we are not used
to recognize that but the fact is that
it's uh it's very uncomfortable and so
our brains are not
um settled in a in a way until we're
able to manage the ambiguity and so I
think in this particular image with a
dog once that our brain realizes oh it's
a dog now we don't need to keep going
with the snow storm and analyzing it and
trying to figure out what's there we
have a dog and that's our shortcut to
this image so that's a very useful skill
to be able to develop and to apply in
the future if I'm ever faced with this
image with this situation again which
here is a Dalmatian dog but it could be
a real life Predator I'll be able to
recognize it and I'll have my shortcut
and I can act quickly without spending a
lot of resources that may be very costly
and then presumably you're able to see
that capacity to subsequent Generations
because you were able to escape that
Predator because of that shortcut that
your brain used to recognize this danger
in the environment so Rodrigo that
speaks to
to both The evolutionary utility of the
computational shortcuts that the brain
takes to gain some story about what's
happening in the objective reality but
also speaks to to memory as a vital part
of what shapes how we see the external
world and I know that's an area that you
have spent a lot of time researching so
maybe just first as an overview what is
the role of memory and everything that
we're talking about here tonight
well I mean memory and perception they
are quite interlinked no because memory
impacts perception and perception of
course impacts memory so there are two
different functions of the brain but
they are interacting with with each
other what I really like to see is is
there's a general principle that I think
applies both to perception and to memory
and you're talking about evolutionary
advantages and so on let me give you a
very simple example and the example is
when we learn how to read and when you
get a child that starts reading I mean
they will go letter by letter
and then at some point I mean they were
they will construct the words or the
syllables and at some point they will go
sea level by syllable and then word by
word and we when we read a book we don't
even go where by where we just jump I
mean we just jump I mean we leave all
the Articles aside we just jump from
words to words I mean and we go much
faster because we don't want to spend
the time in reading all the things that
we can't fill in we know what what the
article it is because we know we have
read many books we don't need a need to
process this information it's a waste of
time right and I think that's more or
less how it works with vision and how it
works with memory so they were the way
our memory works is is basically you
don't want to remember everything that
happens to us because otherwise it will
be too much information and what you
want to do is you want to extract the
meaning from what is happening remember
a few events selling events and then you
construct a story in your head you give
an interpretation
let me give you another example if you
watch a movie you will not be able to
recapitulate the whole movie from
beginning to end but you don't want to
do that you want to remember the
argument of the movie and maybe telling
the argument of a movie just a couple of
minutes but you don't want to remember
one and a half hours you want to
understand the movie and understanding
the movie is exactly this process of
getting very little pieces of
information and then trying to construct
a story about it yeah I know there's a
powerful short story I read some time
ago about an individual who cannot
forget anything
and and and the trauma that that creates
in a life if you had 100 accurate memory
of everything that you ever encountered
that's a story from a writer called
Jorge Luis Borges an argentian writer he
told historical funes and memorials and
it's actually about a guy that cannot
forget I'm first you think well that's
great because I mean I will do great at
University at school I mean if I can
remember everything my exam I will get
top marks and so on but then bork has
realized as well actually if you don't
forget anything then you start to
struggle because you cannot really sink
properly yeah yeah yeah I can imagine
you can't you can't see the forest of
the tree I mean it's like you're just
overwhelmed by the detail
um so we're doing I want to drill down
on one particular
relevant discovery of yours to the
conversation that we're having right
here I don't know if you like the name
or don't but it's usually called the
Jennifer Aniston neuron
where you know you had this amazing
discovery of neurons responding to very
specific stimuli in the external world
can you just take us through that that
episode a little bit and give us some
sense of what you extracted from it the
experiments are it's a very it's a very
simple story there are some patients
that the epileptic patients um for
clinical reasons they get implanted
electrodes inside the head and the
reason for doing that is to try to cure
them from epilepsy because then the
doctor will try to localize where the
epileptic seizures come from and then
evaluate the potential surgical
intervention that may cure the patient
and so on now there are many technical
details that I will escape but the idea
is that these patients they stay in the
hospital for about one week or so and
then they have the electrodes inside the
head the electrodes implanted and this
gives us the amazing opportunity to try
to understand what the neurons were
recording from what are they doing
and then when I started to get involved
in these experiments at the time was at
UCLA in California I started showing
pictures so I would put the laptop in
front of a patient and I will show
different pictures and I will see what
the neurons I'm recording from are doing
and the Jennifer Aniston neuron is
nothing more nothing less that finding a
neuron that will respond to Jennifer
Aniston but not just to one picture of
Jennifer Aniston to any picture of
Jennifer Aniston and I did a search in
Google Images very quickly I tried to
get pictures as different as possible
because I thought well I said really
this picture that is triggered in the
firing of the neuron or is it her and
then I I just came up with seven
completely different pictures of her
different poses different profile
different haircuts and so on and then
even responded to all of them and to
nothing else to nothing of all the other
the other pictures I showed so this was
telling me okay the new one is far into
her it's far into a concept in this case
the concept of Jennifer Aniston so that
was the first and that was the main
discovery but then as I found the
Jennifer Aniston neuron there were many
others I mean another patient I found
one far into any picture of Halle Berry
and also if I wrote the name whenever I
wrote the name Halle Berry then you're
on fire and notify wrote other names so
the interesting part the interesting
point is that these neurons are in an
area that is known to be critical for
memory it's called hippocampus and it
makes sense that we have neurons far
into Concepts to obstructions in this
area that is a memory area because
that's the way we remember we tend to
forget details and we tend to remember
more Concepts and associations between
Concepts oh that's the primary way of
remembering that's a skeleton of our
memories I will argue and so most of us
who are not neuroscientists but sort of
think about these ideas
I think I mean I've always assumed that
a complex concept like Jennifer Aniston
right that's a complex high level
concept
would require all sorts of neurons to be
interacting in some complex Network that
would be required to bring up that
higher level notion of a of a human
being of a particular sort living in
this particular time period and so forth
but you're saying
that's somehow a single neuron can
capture that concept is that the main
import if it is a single neuron I mean I
should be playing Roulette in Las Vegas
because I will be the luckiest scientist
in history I mean if there's only one
here I'm far into Jennifer that's true I
mean I should be very very lucky so a
very simple argument shows you that well
if I found one neuron they have to be
more yeah I just found one out of I
don't know how many maybe thousands in
this area and so on
but then the second point is that these
neurons are not alone in the brain so
Depot campus the area where we found
these neurons is very high up in the
level of processing visual information
so if you imagine that you start from
the eye the retina you go to the
lateralogenicular nucleus then you go to
B1 in the back of your head if you if
you start drawing all the areas that is
that are involved in the processing of
visual information I mean there are a
huge number of steps and at the very top
you end up at Depot campus so why do we
have newness in Depot campus finding in
this remarkable way in such a complex
way well it's because this is relying on
many areas before that has been
processing the information so I will say
the Jennifer Aniston neuron is not there
on its own it's actually getting the
information from previous areas that
process different aspects of of the
picture of Jennifer Aniston herself can
I jump in there yeah please
so you know I think for me I had this
experience of learning how do we make
sense of other people's faces
um that resonated with you know a very
basic principle which is when we are
looking at other human beings we're not
looking at their nose and their mouth
and their eyes and the in the specific
care looking at those local features we
look at the Gestalt so there are there
is a nose shape that's Jennifer
Aniston's nose there's a haircut that's
her iconic style but when we're looking
at Jennifer Aniston we look at the whole
picture and not just not the basic
features that that make her up and
that's true for all people that we have
a lot of experience seeing a good friend
of mine once had played a game with me
she asked my husband who was who is not
my husband at the time
um to take pictures of his hands of his
nose of his foot of a part of his hair
and she asked a bunch of our friends to
do that and then she put an array on the
screen and said which one is your future
husband's nose which one is your future
husband's hair which one is your future
husband's foot and I failed even though
I was about to marry this man and I had
seen his face send his and and all of
him for years and years and years I
couldn't pick out the local features
because that's not how we see people
especially people that we have a lot of
experience looking at we look at the
Gestalt we see the Gestalt not their
nose separated from their eyes separated
from their hair again it goes back to
the idea that our past experience really
informs our pers or how we perceive and
when it comes to seeing faces we don't
see the local features we see them all
together in configuration and was your
husband convinced by your Gestalt
explanation or did he
well he married me nonetheless so I
guess it worked great so so it's a
wonderful interplay between the physical
stimulus and all the other architecture
from memories and experience that we
hold inside of our heads and it's out of
the Collision if you will between the
higher level memories and experiences
and the lower level data that the eye
takes in that this ultimate image of the
world is built inside of our heads now
there's a powerful example of this Emily
that I think everyone in the world is
familiar with it was this example of the
Blue Dress the white dress that just
sort of took over the Internet some
years ago
can just tell what what happened with
this why do you think people got so
worked up about this particular example
I mean this is another example just of
how we are so convinced that what we are
seeing is the right way to see it we
have a sort of naive realism that what
is coming through our eyes and the
experiences that we have are true and
accurate that's why visual Illusions are
so fun fun because they defy what we
believe to be true so we naively believe
that what we are seeing is accurate it's
the way that things really are so when I
see this as a white and gold dress I
cannot understand how someone could see
it as blue and black or whatever it is
that they actually that they experience
and because we are so convinced that
what we see is right and because this is
such a powerful illusion it's actually
one of the illusions that was most
polarizing in society that you know it
was so The Story Goes ripping families
apart it would have like have these
tremendous fights at the dinner table
because you know they're like you're you
either must be lying or you're stupid
that you are seeing this as blue and
black because it is white and gold the
illusion is just that that powerful that
um you know that it's one of these that
that has sort of Taken on a legendary
status in the world and so is this an
example of something that is a is a
powerful party trick or is there real
science that follows along the lines of
of what we've been discussing I mean
Susan what's your take on on this
example
this illusion has been so important for
visual science and it was a whole new
category of Illusion and uh we're
talking about 2015 and uh people are
freaking out on social media and visual
scientists are freaking out that uh you
know in our in our correspondence and at
academic conferences because nobody
knows what's going on and with these
highlights is that there is this uh
range of individual differences that we
didn't know about so so let me explain
so this is a color illusion so we know
about color Illusions we know how
something can look one color versus
another depending on contrast contest
Etc as we have been discussing but
mostly everybody saw the same thing in
the same wrong way for the same exact
image but here we have an image in which
half of humanity is seeing it one way
and half of humanity is saying it the
opposite way and now we have more of
these examples but back then this was
something completely revolutionary about
what it revealed how important
individual differences can be in
perception and so what are the
individual differences like what have we
learn like why is it that half of us see
it one way half the other
well it's still sort of like a work
under progress but what
the consensus seems to be more or less
right now is that if we talk about the
original dress image this was
photographed Under The Perfect Storm of
uh ambiguous illumination conditions the
picture of the original dress the
lighting is a mixture of yellow and blue
light and so when you discount the
illuminant when your visual system is
trying to Discount the illumination
conditions to arrive at the true color
of the image different people are going
to be discounting either the bluish part
of the lighting versus the gold and
parts of the lighting there may be an
evolutionary aspect as well here because
as it happens blue and yellow have been
the lighting conditions under which our
visual system has evolved the blue of
the sky and the golden light from the
Sun so
it appears to be and this is still under
um investigation and other Russian
scientists for instance uh Pascal
Wallace here in in New York City has
done a really good work in this type of
Illusion but it seems that those people
who see the dress as black and blue they
are interpreting the dress as she fits
under direct sunlight whereas the people
that see the dress as white and gold
they're interpreting this is mostly
unconscious of course but they're
interpreting the dress to be in the
shade and why is it then that some
people interpret the dress as uh being
in the shade versus being in the direct
sunlight the best answer that we have
right now that this is probably about
our priors perhaps our previous uh life
experience with this type of uh lighting
conditions but again this is this is a
research that is being actively done
right now so the question that that
brings to mind for me is can you
disambiguate how we see the dress by
giving us just a little bit more in the
image that will make it clear whether
it's direct sunlight or perhaps you know
later in the day Blue Sky can you will
will then we all agree on the the color
of the dress yes it it has been done and
in fact but the actual dress and that uh
in frawali was a vision scientist they
actually they purchased the trash and
they would wear it at Vision conferences
but the actual dress if you see it under
white light everybody would agree that
is black and blue so it's really an
issue of what the illumination
conditions are and there have been
demonstrations at Vision conferences in
which scientists have brought the actual
dress and very delighting and how it
look one way versus another Rodrigo you
can against by that explanation is that
what the cause of all the upper orbers
about
for me it's white and gold no matter
what I cannot see how people can see
this in blue
so I just want to do one final uh topic
before we wrap up here and Emily it has
to do with
work that you've done which has kind of
like a real world impact of you know
expectation and and and bias when it
comes to interpreting things in the
external world and you studied I gather
body cam footage and and had some
striking insights into the way that
various distinct people will interpret
the same footage can you just take us
through that a little bit sure I mean
the idea here is that video footage is
making its way into the courts at you
know at an exponential rate but not only
the legal courts but the court of public
opinion as you know videos documenting
altercations between police and
civilians or members of two different
social groups maybe a black man and a
white man are surfacing
um and then and then going viral and we
are all acting as jurors whether
actually sitting in the courtroom doing
it or or sitting at home and talking
with friends and family about what's
happening in the world around us you
know an example that we found what you
know it was an altercation between a
police officer and a civilian it was it
was a fairly routine pullover and and
there's some conversation that happens
first and and the civilian is is
resisting the requests of the police
officer the police officer goes to to
restrain the civilian on the hood of the
of the police officers Cruiser we're
seeing the perspective through the
dashboard camera actually so we can see
both parties which is important here and
uh even if you're watching it with audio
it helps to understand what's going on
but without the audio it's our visual
system that's left to interpret what it
is that we're seeing there's one key
moment that's depicted in a still shot
that we can share which is that this the
police officer now sort of has the
civilian in a choke hold and the hands
of the civilian are down here by the
police officer's hands and you see this
dramatic arm movement and it's it's it's
a it's a powerful moment because it's
the moment what we're seeing is right
before this the police officer then
strikes the civilian on the back of his
head with a closed fist it looks it
looks like a punch it looks like a very
strong strike to to the to the back side
of the civilian and because of this big
movement this big arm movement that
takes up a lot of visual space within
the video footage that's where our eyes
are drawn our eyes go up to where that
movement has happened what that means is
that we miss what's happening down here
where the hands are where the police
officers hands are where the civilians
hands are and generally when you ask
people is has the police officer engaged
in use of force a lot of people will say
yeah why is he punching the civilian in
the back of the head right that that's
extreme he has him restrained he's he is
he is he's on the hood of the car he's
not flailing around and so this this
punch this strike is unwarranted and
that is because what we have that's what
our eyes have seen that's where our
attention is drawn and as a result we
miss what's happening what we're missing
is that the civilian has
um drugs in his hand that he's trying to
pass from one hand to the other and that
then he puts into his mouth to swallow
and and he's biting the up police
officer and we miss that we missed that
entirely because we are attending to
this area of the video footage so we're
missing what's happening down here so we
have this very rich you know visual
input but it's actually really
complicated even if an altercation lasts
you know a minute or 30 seconds and
that's that's a critical moment there's
so much that happens within within
videos as two people move within space
within time it is actually overwhelming
for our visual system to take in all of
it with precision and accuracy and to
understand exactly what it is that we're
looking at and then when we extrapolate
from that if the understanding is like I
may not have seen everything that's
actually there and in fact I can't
nobody can and know that That's the
basis for consequential decisions like
should this person be put to put in jail
should this person be fine should be
relieved of of their position then we
can understand how you and I might have
very different decisions come to a very
different decision about that about
who's the bad guy in this video despite
the fact that we all saw the very same
thing Suzanne what's your take on this
example so this video
it reminded me of a magician principal
which is uh magicians they have these
Saiyans and one of them is that a big
motion covers a small motion and so this
often happens in magic tricks the
magician may be doing a very wide motion
of the arm that captures attention and
the fingers may be doing something that
is imperceptible to the audience even in
plain view so I I just thought of that
and I think it's also interesting that
uh how we have this dual limitation in
our perception we have talked about how
the phobia is uh the highest resolution
part of our retina only equivalent to
the width of our thumbnail at arm's
length and everything else is low
resolution but uh to that we have to add
our attentional Spotlight which
interestingly attentional Spotlight is
uh a metaphor that both neuroscientists
and magicians use but we what that means
is that everything that we're not
actively paying attention to were
actively suppressing our brain is the
magician's Confederate so to speak and
so we're constantly suppressing whatever
we're not focusing on and this can
mislead us on occasion as in magic
tricks and perhaps with some of these um
confrontations footage but it can also
be positive because uh it gives us focus
and oftentimes
people ask me well what can I do to
overcome this uh
inability to multitask I would like to
be able to multitask to do things at
once we can't we're not wired for that
what we're wired for is focus and that's
really our superpower but uh basically
in every realm of um human activity
without this ability to single-mindedly
focus and suppress everything else that
is not relevant we wouldn't have art we
wouldn't have sports we wouldn't have
science so so it really is uh is an
advantage and so you I mean as a
scientific research studies was on
you've actually studied magicians and
and how they execute their craft I mean
do you find that magicians have some
kind of like intuitive understanding of
the kind of things that we've been
speaking about here tonight so they can
leverage the shortcuts of the human
visual system
toward the end that they seek they they
often do there there are different kinds
of magicians though and uh and The
Magicians that we have tended to
collaborate with they're not just
performers they're magic theorists and
so magic theory is this field of magic
where magicians really wonder about what
makes magic work in the mind of The
Spectator and and some of these
magicians they will read some of the
Neuroscience literature and are well
acquainted with uh the general
principles and that uh and others may
not but but they still have hypothesis
and there are treaties about magic that
have you know for many decades magicians
have hypothesized in as magic theorists
why magic works and so we have had the
opportunity uh actually to do a couple
of uh experiments with magicians in
which we tested their hypothesis in the
lab about why magic might work and in
some cases is The Magicians were correct
in other cases they were not and so this
uh this was um interesting because up
until that point we felt that we had
benefited from Magic methods and
miserection techniques to use in the
laboratory to further our research and
to learn more about the mind and the
Brain but we then realized that we can
also help magicians by applying the
scientific method and help them test
various magic theories and I think we
have one particular magic demonstration
perhaps you can use that as a small case
study so maybe we can pause to roll in
the video hi my name is Patrick Terry
and I am thrilled to be here at the
world Science Festival my background is
in Magic specifically the theory and
practice of sleight of hand and I'd like
to demonstrate when of my favorite
pieces it involves the four famous Aces
that you'll see here and 12 other cards
which I will display in small columns
that's one two three four five six again
we can move them how we like seven eight
nine ten eleven and twelve uh 16 cards
will start and will also end with 16.
now I'd like to put your attention on
the Ace of Hearts we're going to start
with this column first again you'll
notice we have one two three cards and
the ace of hearts
four cards
one ace Don't Blink
one
two
three
and four
and you'll notice that the ace
completely disappears again the front
and backs of each card so you can see
now what's going to happen going to
attempt to vanish all the aces now it's
a little trickier because you know what
to look for
Ace of clubs is next
this one will be very quick that's one
two three cards and the Ace of clubs
once again
Don't Blink
Ace of clubs on the table that's one two
three
and four
and once again the ace completely
disappears two down
two to go now Ace of Diamonds is next in
our pattern and just again you can see
our three in different cards in this
case I'll give you a more genuine
advantage
I'll keep these facing down so you only
have to watch the one ace of diamonds
I'll count very slowly that's one
two
three
and four
Don't Blink
one
two
three four
and the eights completely
disappears
but the thing I like about this trick is
they aren't simply vanishes the aces
actually
transport so now you'll notice that we
have one two three and four aces right
here before your very eyes as though by
Magic alright so wonderful trick
wonderful trick
what Insight can any of you provide to
what we just saw Suzanne I think I
actually work with that magician is that
correct is that one of yeah yes yes yes
I saw Patrick Terry he's wonderful
um it
One important principle I I think in in
Magic I often think of it as a working
as an onion you have all of these layers
upon layers of misdirection and so one
uh particular point that uh there's
there are several points but uh let me
start with
multitasking this is a trick but that by
its very configuration is forcing us to
multitask because we have all of these
different locations where the four aces
are going to disappear and eventually
reappear we have for a possible
locations on the table and so we're
keeping trying to keep track of various
things going on at once visually not
only that but Patrick is using this what
magicians call patter he's a
storytelling he's capturing not only our
auditory sense but also is creating this
internal dialogue so we have all of this
the visual part the auditory part are
cognitive
speculations about the trick as it
develops they're conflicting for our
attention is it is really a divide and
conquer approach
and and so is it the case for instance
that you know where I or somebody in the
audience if they were hearing impaired
or couldn't you couldn't be distracted
by the the auditory patter with the
trick not work as well if without that
distraction it would still work because
like I said these are many layers no
magician is going to rely on this one
little thing that so they have a lot of
bulletproofing so if something fails you
still have something else going on and
so I really it shouldn't be exposing any
magic secrets that we don't have to but
for instance
um a
part of what's going on here as well is
that there's an expectation of a pattern
so Patrick makes the first three Aces
Disappear by the time that you get to
age number four you think that the same
thing is going to happen your brain is
supplying this shortcut based on prior
expect prior experience you have this
expectation and that works against you
also we have spoken about perspective
Advantage points again not to disclose
too much but this trick would look very
different if you were standing from
behind Patrick as opposed to in front of
him got it Emily any thoughts on the
relationship of the technique of the
magician to manipulate our gaze and the
work that you've done on on seeing where
the Gaze of the audience looks for
instance in in video footage and
eyewitness testimony
the idea is that we set up an
expectation that we come in thinking
this is the way that the world works or
in the case of just watching that magic
trick now especially as he does it once
and then he does it twice and he does it
three times we form a hypothesis about
what's happening what's he really doing
when we watch him do that trick the
second time we watch him do it the third
time we're not watching to take in
everything that he's up to we're
watching to test our hypothesis and
we're looking to confirm that our
hypothesis is true everybody's brain
goes about testing their hypotheses in a
biased way that we are more receptive
and we look for information that
confirms what we think should be true
and we are less open to information that
tells us that we're wrong that's just
the way that the human brain works we
don't give both sets of information
equal weight which is why some of these
magicians are able to pull off the
sleight of hand tricks that they do
because they've set up the expectations
that we then in a biased way go out
testing when we've looked at this within
our lab we've seen a similar pattern not
just with like what do people think
about what information do they accept to
confirm a hypothesis but what are their
eyes doing and we've we along with other
researchers have called this visual
confirmation bias that when we're
looking at a scene we're not looking to
take in everything especially if we have
an idea about what it is that we should
be seeing so we go about looking at the
world in a biased way and it's in a way
that allows us to maintain that belief
that what we first thought was true is
in fact true you've also found that that
one's frame of mind one's expectations
one motivation can change our
interpretation of a task or or the
environment in a way that may allow us
to do better than we otherwise would for
instance in sporting events and so forth
can you just give us a a sense of those
results
sure so if we take the idea here that we
have limitations on our on what we can
focus on what our fobial view can
process at any one point in time it can
lead to these unfortunate or it can
serve as an explanation for this
polarization in society about how we
interpret video evidence but we can also
use that same principle of visual
experience that narrowed focus of
attention like what we can focus on is
relatively limited and use it to our
advantage we've spent we've spent you
know 15 years studying how can we take
advantage of that limitation of our
visual experience and help people
exercise more effectively
so this you know this investigation
really started when I uh had the
opportunity to interview some of the
world's fastest Runners some um gold
medal Olympic uh athletes sprinters long
distance Runners and ask them what are
you looking at as you're as you're
racing to the finish line and trouncing
the competition uh I am nowhere near
that level in fact some days I can
hardly run at all so it's not surprising
that what I thought they were looking at
is exactly wrong I thought that they had
some remarkable powers of sight that
somehow they could take in their
peripheral vision they know where they
are relative to the competition at any
point in time and and focus and being
focused on the finish line but that's
not what they do they say I whether they
are a long distance or a short distance
Runner that they have they've chosen a
Target they focus on the finish line on
the next Bend in the curve somebody up
ahead who's wearing bright pink shorts
they almost put on blinders in a sense
and they tune out what's in the
periphery they it's like a spotlight
shining on a Target that they've decided
to focus their attention on
when they and that's that's a trick that
they've used or that or that they think
contributes to their success when we
teach normal people like myself like my
sister like my friends to do that same
thing that the Olympic Runners do first
of all they can those are easy
instructions to follow choose a Target
focus on it and don't pay much attention
to what's on the periphery what we found
is that that induces an illusion of
proximity that that finish line or that
Target now appears 20 to 30 percent
closer than it does if we look around in
a more natural manner paying attention
to what's on the left and the right and
in front of us that illusion of
proximity is really important that
visual illusion that that finish line is
actually closer than we would otherwise
see it it has this whole cascading
effect on our psychology now it seems a
little bit easier to cross the finish
line faster because it seems like it's
closer than it is than it would
otherwise appear to us we believe in
ourselves more we haven't experienced a
self a self-efficacy that we otherwise
would lack uh and that translates into
improved performance so again when we
taught people to use that narrowed focus
of attention that the Olympic athletes
use not only does that Finish Line look
closer but people actually move faster
they move 23 percent faster to the
Finish Line when they engage in the
exercise and we're standing there with
our stopwatches timing them when we ask
them how did it feel they said It felt
17 easier the task is the same the
finish line is the same distance for
everybody it's just that visual illusion
of proximity changes their psychology
their expectations for themselves and
that translates into improved
performance in that moment in our lab
when we teach them that strategy and
then say why don't you try it for the
next week use a fitness fitness app to
track how you're moving where you're
walking what you're doing how you're
exercising and do you mind if we take a
peek at that app at the end of the week
what we see is that they go out for more
walks in the week they take 85 percent
more steps on those walks and they
travel about three quarters of a mile
further
um in in during each walk and again
that's it's it's not magic it's that
that change in the visual experience of
what we're directing our attention to uh
changes changes our psychology which
leads us to feel like this is easier
than I thought it would be and then I'll
try it again and and and have this
impact that it wouldn't otherwise so I I
think we all agree that the shortcuts
that the human brain takes evolved
through our own Evolution as a species
because of the particularities in our
historical past that may have favored
one particular brain approach over
another and allow that to seed future
Generations can you imagine that one day
we encounter say extraterrestrial
intelligence life and we're able to
communicate with them we find a way of
communicating with them but their view
of what the external objective world is
is radically different from ours because
of the way that the evolutionary history
on their planet has biased and created
certain shortcuts in their alien brains
can you imagine that disjuncture between
two intelligent life forms that can
communicate about a supposedly objective
world
imagine the following imagine that I
tell you okay I follow your argument and
I say well there's an alien species that
they don't actually have eyes they just
sense magnetic field or electric field
and they just emit Electric Feel around
it and then they they just sense this
perturbation of electric field and the
whole perception of the world the whole
reality is given by how they resends the
electric field they just emit actually
this exists I mean these are fishes in
the amazonas I mean the world is just
that it's electric fish that you can
catch in in Brazil so that's why
sometimes it's interesting to study
other species you don't need to think
about aliens you need to think about
different species that they were more on
olfaction I mean or they were more on
auditory or they were more in this case
on sensing electric field and it gives
you a completely different view while I
don't know I cannot feel like an
electric fish but if you start imagining
how it may work I mean how the
representation of the reality is for for
these different species I mean then you
have your your aliens and then you have
a different type of thoughts and and way
of of coping with things yeah so as soon
as the fish begin to speak we can begin
to compare different ways of talking
about the world so is this on a final
word on that yeah to to build on that
what uh Rodrigo has expressed we have uh
yes a multitude of aliens here in our
own Planet earlier when we were
discussing color I I meant to say that
uh when we were talking about how the
color that we see may be wrong or it may
not match reality well color does not
exist in reality we have wavelengths but
color exists in the brain color is
itself an illusion or a brain construct
if um you can you can think of it
because our experience of color are
visible spectrum for a human being is
going to be very different to what uh an
insect can see for instance and that uh
we don't know what it is to see in the
infrared or in the ultraviolet end of
the spectrum so yes we we don't need to
to rely on sci-fi to start asking these
questions absolutely well Emily any
final thoughts on on on that question
I just I resonate with what everybody
has said and just say like they're
aliens aliens Among Us already the
sharks that that read electric Fields
electromagnetic fields and you know any
any animals that that we get to
experience maybe on a more everyday
basis that have eyes on the sides of
their heads rather than on the front of
their heads and once we start realizing
uh or thinking outside of our own
physical construction we can we can
realize that there's a lot more
diversity out there that can give us
insight into what the aliens we may
eventually encounter uh how they
experience the world yeah absolutely
well thank you all it's been a
fascinating conversation on visual
Illusions and the brain and the nature
of reality and how we interface with it
and thank you so much for sharing your
insights on this topic with us today
[Music]
thank you